[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is
incredible this is Andrew Reynolds
Reynolds like channels that's how I
learned how to say it Andrew Reynolds
who is incredible I loved him on girls
The Book of Mormon are you kidding me we
covered that he was the lead baby in the
Book of Mormon also so many other
wonderful things he's the author of the
new wonderful book Uncle of the year uh
you gotta check that out as I compliment
him in the episode not only is it
beautifully written and wonderful but he
also performs the audiobook impeccably
and with a lot of humor and glistening
glistening Talent so check out Uncle of
the Year such a great book and enjoy
this chat I'm so glad you guys are here
I'm currently touring if you guys want
to see me on the road go to
petehomes.com the next dates coming up
are I believe New York City I think
there may be a handful of tickets left
to my shows in New York City thank you
to everybody who's gotten tickets
already followed by a show in
Connecticut and then we have some Denver
I think St Louis all at Pete homes.com
check it out means a lot I'm also in Los
Angeles performing once a month at Largo
the next one is August 5th they're
always incredible I'm working out my new
hour so I'm doing new bits come see me
working that out at Largo in Los Angeles
go to
largo-la.com the next one is August 5th
always so fun and thank you to everybody
who came out to the last one it was
incredible we absolutely loved it and if
you like this show the way that it works
is if you want to support it we don't
have a patreon or any way to like donate
but if you want to try things that I
actually use and actually love try a
Pete's pick it helps support the show
this episode is brought To Us by my new
favorite best looking best feeling
shorts I've ever owned bird dogs I've
never been bird dogs I've never been a
huge short guy I love swimming I hate
swim trunks but bird dogs has changed
all that especially now that it's summer
I love liberating my legs and getting in
the water as often as possible and now
thanks to my dogs I can do that while
feeling totally comfortable and looking
really good bird dogs make you look good
they even have stretch khaki shorts
which I love that are designed to fit
Slimmer through the thigh and give your
leg a truly sculpted look bird dog
shorts do the exact same thing as
Lululemon but fit way better and let's
be honest they look better and they're
not Lululemon so that's a plus that's a
plus come on get in it get into it
they're not stiff restricting cotton
bird dogs have fixed this issue by
inventing Cloud knit fabric that looks
just like khaki but stretches so you get
a way Slimmer fit without having to
sacrifice movement and bird dogs use
anti-stink sweat wicking fabric that
keeps you cool and dry all day long and
they're the best feeling quick as drying
best looking swim trunks that I've ever
owned I've actually been giving them to
guests and giving them away to friend so
go to birddogs.com weird you will get a
free Yeti style tumbler with your order
that's birddogs.com weird for a free
Yeti style tumbler with your order you
won't want to take your bird dogs off we
promise you birddogs.com weird alright
everybody enjoy my chat with manupal
Andrew Reynolds
that's flavored zebraf just did it and
he took a sip of that and was not ready
for the cube the Cucumber
while you're drinking compliment alert
it's okay right
zebraf
it's okay but I then I tried and I was
like yeah I mean if you're expecting
plain water yes I was not something when
I was a kid they would be like you know
if someone gives you Coke and they tell
you it's milk and you drink it you'll
barf like doesn't it even if that's not
it doesn't that sound like when you're a
child yeah yeah yeah like like you have
no power so you're looking for those
little we used to do uh because I
watched a lot of Laverne and Shirley
Pepsi and milk what is that was
Laverne's like drink of choice was Pepsi
and milk here's a quick cue
it's what's up dude
just checking no I I just didn't want
you to feel uncomfortable I really that
seemed like that seemed like I was like
what's going on but I just was like
please feel free it's still in the early
stages we're talking peptine milk Pepsi
and milk it's not great but I did drink
it as a kid well my quick instant cue
obviously is you but then like number
two it's not that bad freestyling
is this a freestyle is it's kind of like
coffee coffee milk it's very sweet yeah
it's like an iced coffee so it turns out
Laverne knew what she was talking about
they tried to make Coke coffee do you
remember this well I think they still
have it out there do they and Pepsi has
one too that's like uh they need Pepsi
dark or something it's something like
that that's the dark extra dark
something but yeah they do have a Coke
coffee I think I don't maybe the short
lived like like Crystal Pepsi would you
be short excited did you just that's the
first guess to bring up Christmas before
I can Crystal Pepsi we were on as a kid
we were on some sort of like I think my
mother signed us up to be like
um like a survey family no so we got all
of this in Omaha yeah this is in Omaha
so we got all this like random stuff
um you probably got the first we got
Crystal Pepsi cherry vanilla probably
something gross we did get all of those
WOW chips with Olene which now that I
think about it I thought it was anxiety
but I did have diarrhea for like four
years and it probably was from WOW chips
I think that's what they give you just a
bag of those chips before you get a
colonoscopy now they're just like this
is a better way to like we never piece
that together am I the only one that
wants that like they're like when you I
haven't had a colonoscopy we're I'm also
44. well I would was just at the doctor
this week they said 45. I know
yeah I'm I'm pretty thrilled are you
gonna don't do it well I have a lot of
feelings about it one of them is
well it's vulnerable it's not the
invasion you know it's more like they're
gonna see a part of me that I've never
seen and they're gonna tell me like how
healthy I am and how gross I am so there
is kind of like a get out of my closet
and then you can still see it and then
you get I'm not gonna look you get to
you get pictures uncut gem style you
just you just like I don't wanna but you
are knocked out for it well that's my
second feeling uh Conan on his podcast
talked about getting his colonoscopy and
they said the drugs they give you are
incredible yeah I think you're just like
out I've picked up one friend of mine
after his afternoscopy and he was he was
out was he oh like dead yeah and then I
like you need to have a friend come get
you speaking of Mike can you are my eyes
still super dilated I just had another
exam this morning yeah and I'm saying
well no do you want to dim this could we
yeah I wore do I want glasses I thought
they were my no I do but I don't want to
be that guy but you don't want to well
no it's a matter of being like blinded
I'm not that uncomfortable it was a
couple hours ago but I am like you're as
your prescription changed no okay I'm a
little like what what is your area for
uh oh like medically mine is my brain
I'm like I hate brain I don't like
thinking about my heart I don't like
thinking about my brain the big ones the
headliners yeah yeah so no I get you
I've just been getting like a sharp not
too bad but like a behind my left eye
okay like TLC at least Lisa Left Eye at
least we say go to the doctor so I went
I know face noted I know let's just keep
moving keep moving keep moving keep
moving just keep moving just keep
driving don't stop I hate when I have
something in my eye because your eye
yeah I almost don't even like telling
the listener says I stuff his brain
stuff it's like it can be floaters
things like that yeah it's indicative
it's like where you see other things
it's like the war it's like the but so
far you did it oh I I mean if I was
terrible news
Barack Obama I was
fully expected to be here what's good
news it was good news all right great
because they check your pressure isn't
that interesting they want to see how
much they're bulging out and they're
like if they I know this is heavy no but
it's true but it's true but you got
things you got to think about I just had
to go on a um a Statin
on Crestor what's the status for like
you know cholesterol the fifth Borough
yes
um
for cholesterol because it's just like a
hereditary my dad died of a heart attack
at 61. so my doctor again Dr perky Peck
was like which sounds like a medicine I
know right he was like okay we gotta get
you on a Statin so yeah so just all of a
sudden before my 45th birthday okay it's
like you have to get a colonoscopy and
you're on a heart medication to lower
your cholesterol yeah just to like keep
it in check I also have just two men no
just two men in there
but like we were talking about hair
before we could say well well we'll get
back to that modern mammals get into it
I uh I really like chill aside it's
changed my life I'm excited to try it I
hate washing my hair you look like [__]
for like three days when you have we
were saying off what camera we have the
same hair yeah which and then we went
and complimented each other so it's kind
of which was the chance
or it's like we're just looking in a
mirror
oh us oh us I was gonna say I also have
high cholesterol and it's just
hereditary and and they were like don't
eat cheese and I'm like dude I already
don't really eat cheese I know I know so
what are you on them are you on a pill
I'm not on a pill she said try exercise
more
I was doing cardio three now I'm doing
cardio five six yeah do it I mean I
guess that's what it has to happen do
you I do but apparently that's not
enough so yeah buddy I know so I'm gonna
do it in conjunction with diet and
exercise does that help with because I'm
a new exerciser which is embarrassing to
say no but like I guess I just found it
late because this is why whenever it
comes up I want people to talk about it
mental health anxiety and exercise I'm
like why like okay so I'm in high school
I have a bald spot from stress and I
can't participate in gym class I'm just
kind of like out of shape like like kind
of like too much Mountain Dew and
sitting around Taco Bell oh my God Taco
Bell was like a health food for us
Mexican pizzas at Taco Bell I lived on
that for like for a Wild Cherry Pepsi
and fire sauce
and the cinnamon Crunchies yeah sure God
damn I don't know how I didn't get
scurvy but it's how did we not that's
what their sour cream is made of it's
whipped scurvy I know it's like not
great and I thought delicious it was
[__] delicious I remember when my
friend Eli Blatt that was his name
clearly I didn't make that up was like
you got to get the Supreme because they
put sour cream on and I was like I don't
want sour cream on it because I thought
sour cream was like gross um all of it
well no I I will never go back sorry I'm
just turning this off my boyfriend's
kids wanna they really like Taco Bell
and um he's like no no Taco Bell and I
was like I'll take you to Taco Bell
okay I'll sneak that can I say this is a
relationship yeah there's two energies
and wherever you know what I'm saying
wherever one is this the other's job so
Val we have a little baby well she's
four and a half now but when no she was
a little baby in this house she'd have
something wrong with her and I would
just go the other way if Val was cool
I'd be nervous oh if she was nervous
more more often got it I would be cool
and that's that's the job so if he was
taking them to Taco Bell you would be
like let's let's let me show you because
this is my point bald spot from stress
dude that's crazy someone should have
said have you noticed when you go for a
walk you feel good because I did no one
said that and no one said it because I
feel like in the 80s we didn't know so
when did that sort of clear itself up
well in this house so in the past 10
years there's a little post I just saw
it when I was cleaning up the room a
little bit it says let your body solve
what your mind can't and I was like
that's been one of the mantras of my
life that's a good one I can't can't
think my way out of it like I'm worried
about this or this or this but then your
body can like sweat or something and
you're just like who cares it's fine
it's true who cares so is that part of
your life it is I went this morning a
little I mean it was a little
half-hearted if I'm being honest but I
went I got it I did it in an elevator
after my workout in a hotel this was a
couple weeks ago and as I got off though
because I'm in my shorts and my shirt
and I got off the Hotel this older
couple the guy goes have a good workout
but I was coming from my workout that's
all right and I was like what did he
want like pouring sweat
I feel like at least I went to the gym
sir
I applaud you you want me to Circle back
is that what you're saying also [__] off
[__] off you're old [__] off sir what I
did was killed stairs
you should take the stairs extend your
life
take the stairs okay so tell people hi
no there's no hello there should be
there should be a hello Andrew ramels
it's me Andrew I wanted to show that I
could say your name thank you every talk
show you've ever been on have you looked
at the cue cards and seen how they would
write it out for the host to make sure
yes and often they just told to say
Reynolds but um yeah but
um I believe it was Monique at slate PR
came up with rentals like panels
but she's Australian so she says Ryan
was like panels yeah and then you should
just go you have no business telling me
how to but I liked it Randall's like
panels randles like panels I learned
that a lot yeah David de smalton do you
know him no it's a great name he goes
this small chin and I was like oh my God
these are gifts these are gifts you
gotta yeah well I was gonna give you a
compliment I'm listening to I'm
listening
great hair just for four hours
um your book your second book second
book is called Uncle of the year and
other questionable debatable excuse me
debatable recuse me yeah debatable is
better debatable is better questionable
is like question of the reality events
like are we really here
debatable is the comedy word if you
asked my nieces and nephews they would
go Izzy I bet they dizzy well first of
all you have like 10 of those 10 yeah
it's a lot
too many it's a lot of kids too many I'm
getting to see my brother be an uncle
and it's beautiful he's doing great and
my does he also have kids no all right
see he's in your dedication and he's my
brother's a real steady Eddie he's just
kind of like a quiet
like he's a big guy like broad shoulders
okay and he's quiet so you wouldn't
think that my daughter would necessarily
be obsessed with him but his energy yeah
she loves it she asks about him and all
this stuff so it just melts my heart
it's really beautiful so uncles are the
best but here's the compliment
um you're You're Made Of talent and the
book is so well done and so well read I
know maybe that's silly but I did an
audiobook you're just sitting in a
little closet you are you're bringing it
thank you you're bringing like thank you
very much a real X Factor like when you
hear it you're like this guy Razzle
Dazzle you know what I mean like I get
the Grammy I get the Tony Noms in the
book though you brought it into the book
which is not easy to do thank you it's I
really enjoyed the the audio book
process you can tell I I like doing it I
did it was a little it was a little
different than the first one though I
was
um just finished filming a movie in Rome
with Nick Kroll so I think I saw that on
the ground on the gram so we were we
were in Rome for two months and I I had
to record the audiobook in Rome oh boy
which was very cool so there's somebody
just flapping their hands on the other
side of the class I couldn't always tell
how much the engineer understood the
director was in Scotland so he he was
remote and then I had this Italian
engineer but they understood more than I
thought and the other like cool thing
was that it was at
um this huge Studio where Maura Kone
like did all of his like scores oh no
for like all of these crazy movies so
cool yeah so I and then was in a house
in Burbank I know I was it was way nicer
than it needed to be for me to be
talking about dicks you know what I mean
like it was like all this great work has
happened here and then I'm like and then
the number of masturbation stories in my
book anything greater than three and you
deserve like a shame on you I'm in like
the double digit yeah let's keep it
going but growing up religious what was
your relation I hope it feels like we're
comfortable with this yeah was that mine
my God hates me the only sin I was doing
was was jerking it just constantly you
know what I mean like I wasn't like
thieving no yeah I wasn't murdering no
so but I was like any time they were
preaching on that better yeah or the
fear of Hell sure you're just sort of
like well what am I doing that's like
off menu I know it is it's true I
remember lying in confession as a little
kid because I didn't have anything to
say which oh because the other way we
did our first we made our first
confession in second grade so like
you're asking a bunch of second graders
to confess their sins and like there was
Panic around it that I would like be in
that line how old are you in second
grade I think I was eight or nine I just
I don't like those yeah and I was like
what do I say what do I do so it was
like I would just do like catch-alls
like I just uh I disrespected my parents
I use bad language I I would just like
you're speaking these weird platitudes
[__] [__] [__] [__] I couldn't because
what kind of sins do you have at that
age but also sort of like look I I'm not
even trying to disrespect an entire
institution that I'm sure has a lot of
good going on but also yeah that's my
disclaimer that's a lot of good going on
sure they're great two camera yeah
but
I don't like the training of the okay so
Richard Gore who's a Franciscan he's
like we we I love him he's like my
spiritual father I'm not Catholic but he
goes like we're all obsessed with the
the fall but we're not obsessed with the
inherent goodness of so he points out in
Genesis that God says it was good it was
good it was good it was good it was good
there's five it was Goods before the
Adam and Eve story yeah but no one ever
talks about like the inherent goodness
the original goodness of of us and and
it it it's a little troubling to me the
thing with kids and be like train the
original sin to go in and be like I'm
bad and little Andrew being like
feeling it's like making something up in
therapy because you want to get
something I've done that too
I thought I'd still do it just spice it
up yeah just mix it up
what else do I get
no you know sometimes you have those
sessions where you're like I got nothing
um I had a dream about you so you really
gotta dig deep gotta dig deep
what is it I use the write-in to to find
not bits but almost bits almost bits
being like well that was a funny well I
write about one in this book that
happened in a couple's therapy session
um and with your current no with my ex
and um when it happened I thought
I'm gonna I'm gonna put this in a book
one day
which is so gross but and then I did and
this was before I wrote my first book so
this was like I really was sitting on
this story for a while for two bucks
would you like me to tell it yes I was
that's a good one about it I love it so
we're in couples put a quarter in the
Jukebox no no I'll dance I'll dance I'll
dance for my dad yeah I'll do it I'll
dance for Grandma
um I
Andrew
she'll do it
um
so my ex and I are in couples therapy
and he was maybe like three sessions in
the guy was very nice the um the
therapist and and the ex and um his name
was Mike and so Mike is really going on
like a tirade about like Andrew I
remember specifically some of the things
it was like Andrew sucks the air out of
every room we go into when if we walk
into a room together no one looks at me
everyone's looking at Andrew and Mike is
like you know talking and talking and
he's like can I interject real quick
sure
well it gets it gets better so he's
going on and on Mike is telling this you
know this he's like oh you know just
it's like it's impossible he's so dude
he can be so difficult he can be so
self-centered
and the therapist looks at me and he
says Andrew
did you hear what David just said
and I said Mike and he went what I said
his name is Mike
and he said we had to stop and he was
like I'm very sorry
um he forgot his name he forgot his name
mid rant
about how he's not seen he's not and the
therapist called him by the wrong name
I'm krasinskiing to the camera it was
not great because that is tremendous it
was not great but at the same time I was
like write it down
um well it's a solid bit don't I tell
you one that I had yeah please I'm
dating a woman this is the woman that
got what this is the woman that got me
into therapy okay and I I really every
time she comes up I want to be like
it's tempting to be like it was this
insane relationship and it was bad it
was toxic and I learned so much it was
it was really good so I liked how you
were kind to your ex and I'm trying to
do my better Angels there too any hoosil
she uh we I didn't know what
codependence was I just didn't know I
thought because my mom and I were deeply
codependent and that's who like teaches
you love and I was just like that's what
love is like you just you put your
feelings aside and you're always
together which is always always my mom
and I would go on mom walks I was all
con yeah very heavy Mom okay heavy mom
stuff so then I'm in these relationships
and I'm thinking that's normal that like
we're just constantly
I don't know holding up so somebody said
like you you might be codependent you
should read codependent no more
everybody knows the story but I said to
her I go we should read code no I go I
want to read codependent no more and my
ex goes we should read it together which
is the funniest it's the sunniest
response and we did there was no humor
there wasn't like oh that's hilarious we
we just stepped in it we were like we
will read it together and did you no but
I have it on my phone okay audio all
right now my partner and I uh are pretty
codependent but like functionally
codependent does that make sense oh yeah
do you know what I mean like there's a
line if it's not it's like alcohol I
guess if it's not [__] up your life
you're like this is working for my like
it works if it's working I have a glass
of codependence with dinner that's all
let me know if it's working just a
little bit yeah how are you with your
part good I mean not yeah I would say
healthy not codependent we you know
there's a lot of uh distance built in in
our careers yeah you know there's a lot
of travel is he an actor he's also an
actor and we met working together and we
so we had like a stretch of time we were
doing the boys in the band on Broadway
together and we weren't dating then but
um a year later when we've filmed like a
movie version of boys in the band so
that's when we really started dating but
we worked together
all through that movie we actually
worked together on the show Black Monday
that I was on he was cast like outside
of my own knowledge interesting
um I'm not sure so we worked together on
that show so we were together a lot and
now black money you weren't dating yet
we were oh you were yeah sorry because I
have had friendships that were made by
casting directors like they find the
chemistry like I've been friends with
somebody for 20 years it's because we
were casting a commercial together right
so I kind of thought that that might
have been what was well I think they saw
us in boys in the band together and they
were like that guy would be a good
partner for him so I think it was that
but then I was like actually I'm
sleeping with him
um
so we do have chemistry just like a
classic I don't know of course HR
call HR
um yeah there was no intimacy
coordinator on that set but um but yeah
but the past couple years
um I've been out of town working and
he's been so it's like it's all right
I'm just thinking about the sketch the
the difference between an intimacy
coordinator for gay men I don't I don't
know what the angle would be it's wild
it would be different well I
have I was thinking I was gonna say I've
never worked with one personally but
that's not true because last year uh I
was doing a show called Welcome to
Chippendales I had a couple of sex
scenes yes and I had a couple sex scenes
with Murray Bartlett which is real fun
and I we did have an intimacy
coordinator but they kind of still let
Marie and I just kind of figure out sort
of what we were comfortable with yeah
but I have witnessed other intimacy
coordinators really sort of insert
themselves yeah in the process
um sidebar yeah please one of the things
I feel like the gay community has lapped
the straight Community a million times
over is being vocal about what they like
and don't like sure no that's I think
that's safe to say yeah maybe not
without certainly not with everybody but
I mean like my gay friends tend to be
like I when we start it's like business
we figure this out fast yeah it's like
okay and there's terms and stuff
straight people are like straight people
are straight up it literally in the dark
winging it yeah like it was just like no
that must be sort of getting better I
think it is getting better no this is
something I've learned from the from the
game yeah
learn the terms from the behind the
candle outro the movie behind me don't
judge gay sex on that film
because it was a lot of wincy anal and I
was like this is not realistic
Whimsy anal I was like this is clearly
two men who have never had anal sex
before who are just like everything just
seemed like they were just being like
tortured Oh you mean they didn't seem
like they were into it no they were just
like like the faces they were making I'm
it's funny you bring up that movie
specifically because it was like I
remember watching that and being like
what the Sam Hell is happening
you realize this is sex like you're
happy the direction is you're having sex
and they were yeah it was like they were
being tortured right yeah
sorry maybe that was part of the story I
don't know wincy anal has never been
said in this room before but I'll never
forget what it was I'm happy I can bring
it yet super wincy anal so good okay so
you and intimacy court but we're talking
about you and your ex-partner we were
talking about and now I have a new one
oh the new one
yes yeah so no just to say that like
yeah it's tough and you know in the in
the show biz other professions as well
yeah when there's just like if you're in
a show you're about to be in the
Gutenberg going to do the Gutenberg on
Broadway a big feature I'm gonna frame
it positively I have to assume is that
your partner understands that yes
lifestyle very much so and yeah is it
possible to are you guys in New York no
uh he's in Los Angeles so he'll be in
L.A while you're doing that Joe yeah but
he'll come visit yeah yeah I'm just
touching a sore spot so you won't we
won't really see each other well let's
never see each other
um no we'll figure we'll figure out you
know trips and things yeah visits it's
New York it could be way worse I've been
very lucky the places that I've filmed
have been like like I was just in Rome
for two weeks so I had so many visitors
that was my cue yeah with so many
visitors came to Rome and London because
people wanted to come yes because they
wanted to comment when I was working in
London same thing I was doing a musical
there in the fall about Tammy Faye Baker
tfp yes it was called Tammy Faye the
musical did you watch that I love that
movie yeah this is um this was more sort
of taken from the documentary The Eyes
of Tammy Faye yeah you know film is
based on
um this amazing guy named James Graham
wrote the book for it Elton John wrote
the music with um Jason sellard so it
was yeah so but I mean working in London
people were like oh I want to go to
London so I mean I've had friends work
in some sad places right no one wants to
what is it people want to go to the
Hawaii wedding yeah yeah I mean kind of
kind of you sort of want to go
no a destination wedding please don't do
that
no I'd rather I'd rather die I'd
certainly rather die uh would you
but off Mike uh for the first time in 10
years Katie was just a little bit late
no I'm I'm really saying it she was bit
not late no I no I no she was like on
time but our call to use a show business
term is 15 minutes before you get here
well I mean it all worked out but no
this sounds like I'm for real it made me
appreciate that in 10 years she's never
been late that's incredible it is
incredible I mean you could have led
with that
I mean just in Katie's defense that's
true I could you could always be more
kind
but off Mike we were saying that you
played the king in Hamilton Hamilton and
tell tell me the story tell them
it's been quite some time I know but
since this has happened but no but the
story still makes me like oh we'll start
with how you got it because I thought
that was interesting oh well so the show
was just about to open on Broadway it
had been at the public theater in New
York I was working here at the time in
Los Angeles so I hadn't seen it and it
was also like hugely popular at the
public and sold out the entire run and
um so I had made plans to see it I was
on a waiting list to go see like get a
ticket when I was back in New York and
then I got this phone call from Mr Lynn
Manuel and he said you know Jonathan
Groff is you know has to he's filming
this movie and he has it in his you know
he's leaving for five weeks so would you
fill in and I hadn't seen it
um but all of my agents in New York and
here Los Angeles were like just say Yes
um so I said sure um but can I see it
can I get I'm on a waiting list right
can I get a ticket
um so anyway so I saw it obviously yeah
you took it he got me a ticket
which I mean like who was booted I know
right you know what I mean Hillary
Clinton it was wild that show was wild
yeah um the people that came to see it
um when I saw it that's who was there
Hillary Hillary Clinton yeah I saw with
Hillary Clinton too she came back for
like a fundraiser and I sat behind her I
was just thinking maybe we were at the
same show and then Barack Obama came
when I was in it exactly oh this is such
great great days crazy days I thought
maybe it makes me like sad to like I
mean it makes me happy that we had it
but sad that he's not there yeah yeah
you know but in any event
um so Lynn was like come into the show
so I'm doing the show
um uh if you do you don't know the the
part is King George and if you have not
seen it it's one song you sing three
different versions of the same song
Different lyrics each time twice in the
First Act once in this the second act
it's a very it's like nine minutes of
stage time and it murders yes it's like
this breath of fresh air it goes very
well so I am feeling good I have very
little rehearsal I fit into all of
Jonathan Groff's costumes which I think
is why I was asked and also and also
because then if the audience was like
that's that gay guy from HBO I would be
like yeah that's correct because he was
on looking at the time and I was on
girls so I think the audience was like
get me the other one get to find that
other gay Lynn with a red phone yeah
raise the other game who's the guy who's
six one or two at the max
um so I'm like four performances in
everything's going great the cast is so
nice I'm having so much fun I get on
stage I'm like this is awesome and I
start singing and I sing the second
version the first time oh no so I know
but luckily the cast album hadn't come
out yet so a lot of people in the
audience hadn't like heard it right so
they didn't really know but I knew this
was going to be an issue because the
lyrics weren't going to make sense for
what was happening in the context of the
show so a good 40 minutes to think about
how yeah so I start to sing the wrong
core or the wrong verse and I just
stopped
and I kept moving my mouth because in my
mind in that second I was like maybe
they'll think there's like an audio
issue
can I say so I just kept moving my mouth
and then the conductor Alex lackamore
like shouted from the pit he was like
six feet away from me and was like blah
blah like yellow lineup
so I got back on track pretty quickly no
no I mean he's a very good man for doing
it and I so I finished it and like you
know got through it but immediately was
like flop sweat and my friend Nikki
James who had done the Book of Mormon
with
um was in the audience that night and
she knew exactly what was happening she
knew that it was wrong and she when I
saw her afterwards she was like she was
very sweet about it but she said that
when she when it started to happen she's
sitting in her seat and she just went
oh my God she just fell to the floor
that's the only choice because she was
like I can't believe this is happening
to him he just like this is awful as an
actor isn't it crazy that there are
things that happen in our lives where
liver and surely behaving like Laverne
or Shirley is actually totally do in
reality she said she flopped to the
floor and her fiance at the time was
like what is happening
um but I got through it but the I never
recovered from that I was in that show
for then a few more weeks and I was
never not nervous the stuff is
nightmares yeah yeah never not nervous
that's what Taryn said is because those
songs are similar but someone different
you'd get lost in them sometimes but can
I say the mic thing is pretty brilliant
In the Heat of the Moon yeah I was like
maybe they'll just
forgive a non-theater person asking I
kind of May I I'm just a little worried
it's a basic question did anything else
ever go wrong I mean stuff always goes I
mean something will always go wrong
sometimes it's technical stuff like
you'll have to do you'll be like the
turntable's not working and they'll have
to like adjust around the play where
someone went ring ring and they walk
over and answer the phone I mean and the
actor is like clearly pissed things like
that happen yeah so then you just kind
of have to roll with it and Hamilton is
also one of those shows that's so wordy
oh my God like if you trip up like all
of those actors were so skilled that
like they were able to sort of like
navigate their way out of it yeah and no
one really knew but those those shows
are particularly tough the next show
that I did was the show falsettos that's
like
you know it's like all sung through
there's no dialogue it's like just two
and a half hours of straight singing and
that was another one that was like well
if we mess up and this is and luckily
like I can't remember anything too
horrible happening there
um and is that one of the greatest
Expressions I'm just no so now 44. I'm
going like oh my God all the good stuff
is on the other side of like this could
be a disaster like the best feelings on
the other side of something okay that
could be bad like a song called falsetto
where you have to sing Everything yeah
and then what the rush and the relief
you must have got every night when it
didn't go when it doesn't go around yeah
yeah
this is great yeah but I think also with
age I'm less now I'm sort of less
precious about it meaning if there's a
mistake like if that happened today I
you know I would still be upset or
disappointed but I think I could
probably Shake It Off yeah a little bit
but you're an established
person Emma
um
yeah but you do I mean obviously you
don't want to make a mistake you don't
want to do that but if it does you can
kind of like Shake It Off well I feel
the same way about bombing if I bomb
it's just like but you got to move on
any of other shows yeah but when you're
when you're living by every show at the
beginning yeah really really brutes
there's a yeah you just have to remind
yourself like there's a lot of show left
and you can always get her back and even
at the beginning I remember this was
advice Dimitri Martin gave me and he was
like in New York and I was I had nothing
and I just I just you know it was an
open Miker okay nothing to my name I
mean I had food in an apartment but like
I I was you know yeah the basics but you
know career-wise I was like I felt
invisible and he said uh I'll never
forget he goes there's power in
anonymity he's like you can do anything
yeah you can go up on stage tomorrow and
be a one-liner person you can go up and
tell a story you could nobody knows [__]
he's like I I'm a one-liner guy people
want me to be a one-liner guy like
you're locked into a thing so I love
that reversal yeah that if you'd feel
invisible in new and show business
that's actually your power yeah it's
actually a little troubling that's so
much stuff like I see Tick Tock people
and Instagram people and they are
talented but I'm like you're going to be
so much better yeah and it's going to be
unfortunate maybe it won't be but to me
it's unfortunate that we're seeing these
these this should have been a VHS
that you showed your friends not don't
put it out there how do you feel about
it because it's all over the place like
I'm not on The Tick Tock but on the
Instagram
um Comics putting up like sets right
yeah a lot of crowd work I almost put it
in my Instagram profile uh no no clip
guarantee but it's really realized it's
real and I'm not a I'm not a comic but I
you know I I have taken note that that
is a real Trend well it is unfortunate I
can see it from both sides sure you're a
comic you don't have five specials to
clip yep and then uh what are you gonna
do you kind of have to play the game
some of it that you don't give your
jokes away is that why they're doing
crowd work specifically yeah God I don't
want to give your jokes away and then I
have some friends who are just giving
their jokes away and that doesn't even
work that much better it's really
unfortunate I saw that I'd love to get
your take on this I saw uh Louis CK
Scandal noted he was giving this talk
about about how somebody asked in the
crowd they're like what do you do like
if you're coming up now people won't let
you headline a club if you don't have a
certain number of followers and Louie's
advice and I look I understand
complicated but I usually think he has
really good advice and really sound
practice for come but I disagreed with
him in this instance he was just sort of
like don't do it just don't just like
say no and uh say no to social media and
engage and I was like he was like just
kind of make a good tape and send it or
whatever or people will hear about it
and my feeling was like that's a very
privileged place like if I said that and
look I I think he would hear that I
don't I think he was just answering a
question not saying something to me to
comment on but I so I I think he would
understand what I mean but like when
you're established it's easy to go like
don't don't do it but like what we were
doing was just the version of what they
have to do if it was handing out flyers
or terrible open mics and stuff so I'm
curious about breaking into Broadway
seems like an e like there should be a
crashing about that it seems so strange
to me and so vulnerable singing and
dancing is so vulnerable and and the
compete tell me yeah well no I mean I I
think that's a that's interesting and I
think that it's um the the idea like
when I moved to New York when I was 19
to go to college I knew that there were
you know open calls for Broadway shows
and there were auditions that I could
like look in this publication called
backstage and they would list all of the
auditions in the back of like for
everything for like regional theaters
for Broadway shows so you could there
was something you could do to get in the
door and I always didn't get seen but I
could
yeah you wait in line sometimes you
don't get in sometimes you do you know
that scene's always in the movie but yes
the guy that comes out we're all done by
my headshot
um but yeah just crying
just weeping I spent a lot of time doing
that but it felt like I was doing
something the idea of that the idea of
the people
like to me the the people my age who
moved to Los Angeles in the late 90s to
like I'm gonna break into TV I was like
how the hell do you even do that yeah
like is there an open call to be an
under five on friends like probably not
so I was I was like that seems
terrifying to me but in New York at
least for the musical theater stuff I
knew there was something there was a
liability there's literally a lot that I
could get in that line and there was a
game an endurance game like let's say
it's at 5am or let's say it's at 11 p.m
like you can do that you can do it
because it's your day yeah and you could
wake up early and you could get your
stuff together and like make sure you
were there and yeah it didn't always
work out but I always finish those days
feeling like at least I had thrown my
hat in the ring a little bit so I I
don't know I'm thinking out loud
um I don't know if the new version of
that is like posting videos of yourself
singing on yeah the YouTube and on
Instagram I mean I do know especially
with you know shows with more young
people in it like I know mean girls did
it and dear Evan Hansen like they did
find people from like YouTube clips and
things like that and Tick Tock so the
time that is maybe that's a way to do it
and gone on to YouTube or something yeah
or we'd just go to the UCB website and
just look at the pictures and I was like
they should charge I shouldn't give them
that idea because they will don't do it
don't charge for that that is a service
would you feel like what about the
because they can improvise and they're
in New York why not and like yeah yeah
that's that's so maybe that's a version
I don't know but I was a couple years
ago there was an essay in my in my first
book that was published in in Modern
Love uh in the New York Times and then
in the second season of the television
show Modern Love they asked me to adapt
it so I wrote the you know I wrote the
adaptation of that essay and then
um they asked me to to direct it which
was really crazy because I'd never done
that before but I bring this up because
when we were casting these two young
actors and we ended up
incredible actors that we we got there
was a you know casting directors who
would were referencing their Instagrams
which I was horrified by yeah that they
would be you know I would say like well
I really like this guy I'm like well he
only has 3 000 followers and he's
following 5 000 people so that's not a
good sign I was like well that's not
I don't want to even have this
conversation but unfortunately like that
has and by the way I got my way
um but
um it is it's unfortunate that that does
no I don't concede Josh Peck just he's a
former Disney guy very wonderful guy
with a great book as well
um but he I was embarrassed but it's not
helpful to not share these little
embarrassments he messaged me and was
like hey do you want to do my podcast
and I did check his in like I looked I
hate telling you this now no it grosses
me out but I go like
I I again keeps coming up that I'm 44.
I'm trying to like play the game and I'm
like who's out there should I know who
this person is clearly three million
people know who this person is that did
influence it a little bit it is sort of
shocking sometimes I remember asking
Nick Kroll about a couple Comics that I
were just like always in my algorithm on
Instagram and we would be on set just
like scrolling through our phones when
we were tired of talking to each other
I'm like who is this guy and be like oh
he has three million followers like how
does this person have three million
followers what's going on but it's a
it's possible a game we used to play uh
on set was guess how many followers they
have it was really fun charm you'd look
up like Willie Nelson and like you'd be
like way off and then you'd be like and
then somebody out of the blue I wish I
could think of the example but it would
be like Pierce Brosnan and it's like he
has two thousand people like what's
happening I know sometimes people that
like you're like well this is insane it
is they should have more followers I can
I can see it both ways Marcia Gay Harden
needs more followers that's our company
that's I'm gonna do it I follow her and
it's a it's a good follow who is that
Marcia Gay Harden MGH yeah babe Oscar
winner Marcia Hardin who did she think
who was she she was in um Pollock she
won an Oscar for Pollock she's a very
talented she was also in the original
angels in America okay she was Harper
and Angels America but just shout out to
Marcia Gay just love her I'll be
embarrassed just a fan yeah just a fan
it's a big fan
um but yes but people like that that I
consider to be like well that even
that's a you know a famous celebrity no
and you're like and this girl sells lip
balm my younger friends go they this
generation doesn't know who we sound so
[__] old that's okay but they go they
don't know who uh they might not know
who Brad Pitt is you know that that's
might be too big but they do know who
you'd be shocked yeah that's what I'm
saying I started playing a game at a
dinner party a couple years ago um I was
at a friend of mine's house and her
daughter who's like a junior in high
school had some friends over and they
were talking about talk and and I just
for funsies said do you guys know who
Julia Roberts is fun
now Julia Roberts to me yeah is like
still yeah the greatest movie star like
of our of my life
yes there's like obviously there's the
you know the you know there's Meryl
Streep and there's Jessica Lang and but
like when I was a kid you know pretty
woman and you know all of this she made
that string of like okay
Notting Hill he'll go Notting Hill so I
was like do you know Julie Roberts and
two of these young women were like I
don't know who that is and then the
other one pipes up she's like yes you do
she's the mom from Wonder
and I was like [__]
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at element lmnt healthy
hydration isn't just about drinking
water it's about drinking water plus
electrolytes it makes sense you lose
both water and sodium When you sweat and
both need to be replaced to prevent
muscle cramps headaches and energy dips
but most people are only replacing water
but the solution to getting through your
workout or just getting through your day
with proper hydration to optimize your
body and your mind isn't just water it's
to drink water plus lmnt element has
become a huge part of my wellness
program and a part of my morning routine
that I sincerely look forward to it's
also how I wind down at the end of the
night I drink their chocolate salt
flavor hot which is incredible and
replenishes everything that I've sweated
out during the day when I'm working out
when I'm in the sauna and when I'm just
getting on with my life I always start
the morning with a big glass of water
and a packet of element I love their
watermelon salt flavor best in the
morning just mix it up and you're good
to go makes you feel great no sugar no
artificial junk just elect electrolytes
and great taste gives you the optimum
ratios of sodium potassium and magnesium
magnesium is so hard to get in your diet
helps with health performance and energy
also tastes amazing makes drinking water
such a pleasure and when I'm fasting but
I want to sip something that's flavorful
that keeps my fasting you know intact
It's a Wonderful hack for that an
element has a fantastic offer for
weirdos just go to drink
lmnt.com weird these promo code weird to
get a free element sample pack with any
order when you order and if element
doesn't exceed your expectations they
have no questions asked refund policy
you can literally send it just back you
don't risk anything support your walk
support your body support your water
support this show go to drink lmnt.com
weird to get your free sample pack with
any purchase that's drinkelement.com
weird we're also brought To Us by our
friend at next Evo CBD my absolute
favorite CBD company Val and I are about
to go go on a trip tomorrow which is a
lot of fun but let's be honest it's a
lot of stress and when you need to
de-stress or keep your sleep schedule on
track this summer CBD can help but don't
just settle for any CBD next Evo is off
the charts different from every other
kind I have tried a recent study shows
most CBD labels are way off and some
products contain only 60 percent of what
they claim melatonin products can also
be very inaccurate next evos next next
Evo Naturals CBD delivers exactly what's
on the label their products are tested
before during and after they're made so
you know what you're getting and what
you're paying for and it gets into your
system so much faster that's the huge
difference between next Evo and other
brands you're feeling the difference
within 10 minutes they've figured it out
they've cracked the code you can dial in
that dose just right I love their stress
CBD complex gummies which are CBD plus
adaptogens like ashwagandha and it's
Clay clinically proven to reduce stress
up to 70 percent and no prescription is
needed their triple action CBD sleep
calms your mind with fast absorbing CBD
and then controlled release melatonin to
help you fall asleep stay asleep and
wake up refreshed so leave summer stress
behind and upgrade your CBD go to next
Evo next evo.com weird to get 25 off
plus a free bottle of Premium pure CBD
that's a 50 value limit one per customer
that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash weird support
your body support the show last but not
least our friends at ritual this has
been a huge game changer for me ritual
makes a completely traceable delayed
release multivitamin that has absolutely
changed my health and change my life I
used to go to the doctor and then be
like you're deficient in all these
ritual has changed the game you can talk
fantasy football with your friends all
day but asking them for health advice
it's not really the move ritual take the
guesswork out of the vitamin game their
multivitamin for men is based on science
to help fill common gaps in the diet and
level up your nutrition goals your
nutrient goals it's an all-around win
and because it's delayed release it
actually gets absorbed people are always
talking about peeing out your vitamins
they fix that it also doesn't make you
nauseous sometimes taking multivitamins
on an empty stomach can make you
nauseous not with ritual because of that
delayed release scientifically develop
multivitamin high quality key
ingredients in clean bioavailable forms
ritual is your new type of two a days
from supporting healthy heart function
with omega-3 DHA to normal muscle
function and normal immune function with
vitamin D3 this small step can have a
Major Impact it's traceable it's vegan
friendly non-GMO sugar-free gluten-free
major allergen free and delayed caps
delayed release as I mentioned the minty
Essence also makes it a pleasure to take
it actually tastes good and is part of
my morning routine that I look forward
to essential for men is a quality
multivitamin from a company you can
actually trust and get this ritual is
offering weirdos 20 off during your
first month so please do your body a
favor do the show a favor do yourself a
favor go to ritual.com weird to start
ritual or add essential for men to your
subscription today that's ritual.com
weird alright everybody back to Andrew
as you were talking I just realized
Kieran Knightley ate some of Julia
Roberts's lunch
she I'm just saying Julia Roberts had
she been in Pirates of the Caribbean was
she supposed to be I feel like she could
have been I I'm fascinated by those
those things of like well she was
supposed to be in this oh me too what's
your fave
um I do Eric Stoltz was supposed to be
in Back to the Future
the best ones and the fact that there's
so much footage of it they were shooting
every actor knows that story because
they like don't relax terrifying don't
relax
I know you're here and you're shooting
but don't relax you used to be a pilot
season yes there was one story that kept
surfacing about this one actress who got
fired after the table read because she
didn't wear makeup to the table read and
the network Executives got panicked
about it and it was written for her oh
so it was like always like those stories
[__] terrify me but my yeah Eric
Stoltz is a good one um Gwyneth Paltrow
and Titanic also a good one she was
offered Titanic
maybe somebody can can verify this but
that was that's the story I feel like
it's a harmless if it's not true but
what about Will Smith The Matrix I did
not know that yeah see I love you you
know why I turned it down why
what do you got
Wild Wild West oh well you love Wild
Wild West no but I'm just saying I love
steampunk you gotta make a choice you
gotta make it you gotta make a choice I
don't know I mean um the one that also
like is like real wild to me is Bette
Midler had like a string of real good
ones like she turned down Rocky oh my
God Adrian and Rocky
and then she turned down Sister Act
but it's just funny when you hear those
stories of like oh it could have been so
it would have been so different yeah
Bette Midler is one of those again not
to keep invoking the gay community but
they love Batman I really gate up your
your studio here anal Bette Midler what
was it Wednesdays we didn't see anal
what are your search words
my safe word too
that's true but go ahead Bette Midler I
just that one's missed me I don't know
what I know her and I don't know why I
know her she's sort of like wow I'm like
why do I why are we no okay I haven't
seen it that's a real tear jerker right
oh yeah sad sad sad but why do we know
Michael Caine too I I like well Alfie
see I didn't agency
um I mean you know he's like oh wait
that's Jude love well no he was the
original Alfie oh no Katie's laughing no
he was like he did all the lights in
like the 60s and 70s like he was like
the guy yeah see that's my point is I
don't know what Steve McQueen is for
like I I don't know
I mean that's a he's just sort of iconic
for like the look and the cars and the
right that's what I know him for yeah
yeah and Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
French Connection Steve McQueen yes
right maybe
um but yes but yes like I now I sound
like one of those girls who did that's
what Julia Roberts was well yeah so that
happens on me if I'm talking to somebody
in their late 50s and they're like
you're in comedy nobody better than
I'm like oh I'll check it out and
they're like let me ask you this two two
Quicks one how many lbs if any did you
gain in Rome because Jesus Christ I know
Swedish carbonara what are we to do
um what are we to do it was initially a
lot of walking yeah which is great
because I did walk a ton yeah um but
then when we really got into filming and
we were doing a lot of night shoots and
it was just like and more pasta uh in
the scenes No just like oh just forever
yeah of course it was like Jesus yeah I
gained some weight yeah no it wasn't it
wasn't even it sounds like a fat joke it
was just like I did insane at a certain
point and when you're in Rome you gain
weight well there's that dumb thing that
people tell you like no no no no no the
wheat is different there and the cheese
isn't as processed and it's all better
for you I'm like okay and then you're
like slurping down like plates of this
is unprocessed yes and you're like that
should be fine right and the bad thing
is not the bad thing that well was sort
of bad that um in this particular movie
we only took place over a couple days so
it was multiple versions of the same
costume so you really can monitor your
weight gain and loss because your pants
would fit differently or too funny yeah
how great is Nikki K he's the best he's
the dreamiest I love him he's just I do
too man very very sweet here's the next
cue okay what do you got it's coming in
hot
you went to an all boys Catholic Prep
School
but here's here's the goofy left we're
about to take when I saw a book of
Mormon I saw you in Book of Mormon and
it was absolutely one of the best things
I've ever seen in my life and I grew up
religious and I'm like this show
uh the real one
Protestant
it's the same as you guys just less
smells and bells lazy Catholics let's be
honest we took Jesus off the cross
you're welcome ours is risen okay he's
up there somebody help your lord
somebody help your lord it's very we're
very dramatic you are it's very dramatic
in fact I've changed my opinion I think
Jesus should be on the cross I would
argue that's the point that's that is
the point it's not it is and I don't
mean the sacrifice I mean that's God
saying me too like I am also suffering
and here with you I understand but I'm
sorry I interrupted you hey we just got
a little dash of unexpected theology
we can do it but I'm just curious you're
going into Book of Mormon was it
an adjustment to do something so Fierce
because it's Fierce or did you just love
it I just loved it yeah I loved it and
I'm thinking of specifically God [__]
you you know yeah but not turn it off
turn it off that's adorable we just
needed it uh no but because I knew sort
of you know what was coming
um you know the first time I read the
whole thing I was like oh this is
ultimately
strangely very sort of pro-religion
right Pro metaphor yeah that it was you
know even if you know if it makes you a
better person even if you're talking
about magical [__] frogs and Boba Fett
like you know if you're talking about
all of those things and you're you know
which is what happens in that Musical
that you know Josh gadd's character sort
of just starts making stuff up because
he doesn't really know anything about
the Book of Mormon so and it affects
people and people change and they change
for the better and they're because we're
transformed in the presence of symbols
yes yeah that's Yeah Carl Young
interesting we're not transformed by
ideas or or even people so we need that
sort of stuff yeah so I made it sort of
tan so I knew what was you know
ultimately what the message was but yes
there was you know to watch the audience
particularly early on in the in the Run
sort of react to you know yeah I mean
it's a shocking it's shocking and it
it's uh I am sort of you know got sort
of numb to it oh of course yeah and
you're not not the ambassador of its
shockingness being okay or not okay I
was just wondering if as someone who was
raised raised in that if you ever were
like
Wicked
yeah I had enough distance from my
Catholicism that I wasn't too concerned
but we did have people in the cast who
were religious who were actively
religious who did I think struggle yeah
um and it was there were a lot of
conversations around sort of what are we
doing what are we doing and is this
right and yeah so yeah we there was
definitely a lot of conversations about
it I was not I was concerned because I
was you know had been out of the
Catholic church for quite some time yes
so I wasn't really like hanging on to
that and I'm correct as turning off was
I'm getting this right it was a long
time ago that was your song that was
Rory O'Malley forgiven I was also in
that number no no I was also in that
number but um it was really Rory's okay
big number okay um tap dancing in fact I
they did stick me in the back at the end
of the number I did not have Taps on my
shoes which is a testament to my skills
you were the Jesus I just realized
you're the main guy you're the yeah I'm
the lead babe yeah you can say it did
you say [__] just did
I thought you stopped yourself right now
we were no Josh was your assistant no
yes no Josh yeah no Josh and I you said
I'll do it but I have this assistant I
have an assistant and he has to be on
stage
um no but that was a very important
lesson as an actor
um to be in that room with him and be in
the rehearsal and just sort of accept
that we could both be funny but both
have different lanes because I think
they had replaced my character of Elder
price like multiple times doing readings
and workshops and they were always
casting somebody new and I was the last
one they brought in and I think I think
part of the reason that I that kept me
was because I wasn't trying to compete
with Josh because I knew there was no
way I'm not going to get the laughs that
he gets like it's just not yeah that's
not my thing
um he does it so well and is so funny
that I was like I'm gonna stay out of
his way and I will find other things
mostly in reaction to him wow that will
help us both out and it did and we've
developed like a really good and and in
preparation for doing Gutenberg uh the
musical in the in the fall like we we've
just been doing sort of like you know
press stuff and you know videos and
things like that to promote the show and
um we just sort of fall right back into
that yeah it's a good it was a very good
lesson to be like you know don't compete
with that guy because that's not what
you do and if I was trying to do that it
would not work that's brilliant can you
no that's a great that's a great clip I
don't often shout out the clips but I'm
like that's here's why why because I
feel like a lot of people think you do
have to go in and like get it rise and
grind and like today Josh gad's not
gonna
you
slay in that show but you didn't try to
defeat another person you read the room
and there's something it's changed my
life it's it's in Zen it's it's way-woo
way it's the Art of Doing Nothing oh
yeah yeah and I think about this all the
time yeah and in Show Business in
particular
doing nothing
I just had a friend that was like my
agent uh this this and this this and I'm
like do nothing no one tells you to do
that but I'm like just wait because
sometimes you know you do the wrong
thing and relationships are severed
sometimes you get sweaty and start
trying to eat Josh's lunch and you get
recast yeah so that's why I'm like
that's the clip I love that clip it's um
but it's hard to do it's hard to pause
in those moments and like not react and
in any moment not just with acting but
like when you are faced with some sort
of you know problem or issue to like not
immediately try to fix it or react to it
I I've certainly struggled with that a
lot to like just pause yeah just like
give it a second that's right and don't
respond to every email as soon as you
get it and don't return every phone call
as soon as you get it and I said there's
a million if your hands are shaking when
you're replying don't do it stop yeah
that's a good stop yeah it's crazy it's
true but you like it there's something
wicked in you that's like and I'm
or wait I'm gonna say six hours yeah you
will never write what you were gonna
write what no
um I I'm gonna make this even gayer
um my good friend Judith Light
um Judith Light gave me a very good
piece of advice years ago when I was
doing the Book of Mormon which is I
don't know if she still does this but at
the time she had certain hours in which
she would respond to business emails and
phone calls and she would within that
window she would respond to things but
outside of that window she would not
because you know the more you respond to
things then you get another recipe and
then you're just like on it all the time
so if you just let them come in and then
you respond like you read them all and
you're like okay so this is sort of
sorted itself out this is no longer an
issue now I can respond that's that's
pretty great it saved me a lot of time
that's brilliant thank you what's that
thank you Judith yeah I think you just
like for the light advice
um listen I it even applied somebody
from your team was like Hey when's
Andrew's episode coming out and like I
felt like I had to reply to it
immediately I was driving I wasn't
reading it while I was driving but I was
at a red light and I was like I have to
reply to this and it's like
says who yeah it'll come out when it
comes out I also whatever I [__]
wanted to say it's like Andrew doesn't
care
this sounds stupid but one of the things
one I love to Google things you didn't
know about and the guests oh boy and
it's not that good but it's okay but
there's this clip that seems like it
should be an amazing clip and it says
Andrew Reynolds
had sex during intermission in his
dressing room that's on the internet
yeah
[__] Andy Cohen
that's what that's from I know exactly
where that came from but dude it it
comes up he asks you you confirm it and
then we move on and I'm like I'm
brimming with questions
this is a question that Simon Halls
loves when I answer
um my publicist
um
no yeah it came can I say I've had sex
in in my dressing room well you should I
just wanted to know is it the most
incredible you're at an intermission
yeah packed [__] killer show you go
and have sex that was my first question
it was Joy it wasn't like Yik it was
like that had to be a peak experience
yes and it was a bit of a it was a bit
of a challenge the first time it was
like is this possible should we try it
um
and then it was just sort of for sport
you know what I mean yeah it was like a
person I was in a relationship with sure
and I've done it since if I'm being
honest
um but the first time uh was yeah I was
just sort of like um it was a whim it
was like should we do it I mean I'm the
same for you it was like of course
yeah but you're in look creativity and
sexuality I think are similar energies
so when you're in a flow one of my
favorite things to do uh in my marriage
is like I go out I do stand up and I
come home and I'm just sort of like
charged it's the same thing it's not
exactly the same thing no but yeah but
the times my wife was on the set of
crashing it was like this is an
extension of the day yeah it wasn't like
cigarette and mashed potatoes I'm the
king I don't respect anything it was
like this is it's like it's like this is
life yeah and when we're old men God
willing we're old men and we're dying
we'll be like all right that was awesome
I did that and I'm glad I did and the
second here's my other question the
second half of the show great yeah yeah
it can go either way no yeah as I recall
yeah I was like it was a fun thing that
we did and it was like yeah it was fun
because I remember I used to do warm-up
for The Daily Show and I'd be like black
out horny like the horniest I've ever
been yeah I desire to doing it before I
was doing it okay and I said to myself
because I was aware I've always been
sort of obsessive about like Peak
Performance energy creativity and like
Rocky Bette Midler's famous Rocky I
would go like Rocky rules don't have sex
before the show okay like because uh
warm-up is all crowd work yes so it's
it's harder yeah than just being like so
I'm from Boston you have to be like look
and you have to keep it in bounds it
seems like a nightmare it is a nightmare
sometimes it's five minutes sometimes
it's 45 minutes like you don't know yeah
and it's CR it's crazy Mad respect to
people
[Laughter]
I appreciate that but I so I was like
you know every once in a while you get a
10 out of 10 like a junior high horny
and you're just like Jesus Christ all I
can think about is sex it's like the
worst like new hormones horny and I was
like don't do it and then I did the set
and it went great and afterwards I was
clear as a bell like I I had no it was
all energy is what I'm saying you broke
that pattern for yourself is that what
you're saying the the pattern that I
noticed was that like
it was more of an identification of it
wasn't actually horny it was nervous yes
and nervous and that's why I said it
could go either way yeah there's this
look I don't know if this is true but in
Chinese medicine they say masturbation
lowers your cheat your life force but
sex raises your Chi there's also
interesting things about testosterone
too that they say uh when women have sex
it raises their testosterone but it
lowers a man's testosterone very
interesting like what is going on here
oh but there is that sort of like
okay you go what do I do with that oh
all right that's all I wanted to know
interesting well yeah I like that that
came up though on the internet on the
interwebs and I liked honestly I again
as a formerly religious person I loved
how you answered it not on on the show
as well but there unashamed there's a
message there well there it is it's
important I think you know when we did
that interview because I remember
exactly when it happened we were doing
boys in the band I was we were Andy
Cohen was interviewing all of us there's
you know the whole cast is out gay men
that never happens usually there's only
one of us allowed on a set at a time
that's right
um this is again just sort of an
unofficial rule in Hollywood there's a
murder what is a group of gay men
Americans
yeah oftentimes
um but no I felt sort of empowered by
the you know the theme of the show and
being with all of these gay actors and I
was like yeah I'll just say it very
similar two things about your life the
getting in line for Broadway like
there's something to do very similar to
stand up I can go to an open mic
and also when groups of comics are
together there's like it's like
I don't know we become a group identity
and it can be kind of dangerous not
dangerous but like you might say
something or have an opinion more
strongly because you're like with a
bunch of pirates well and I imagine it's
probably it's got to be a little similar
to like
you know doing a show out of town
together or you know if you're like
touring and you're even if you're with
the same people at the open mic like you
do feed off of that energy yes and
especially in my early days in New York
of like being around other people who
are like hungry like that yeah it can be
terrifying but it's also really
motivating yes it's really motivating
you're looking yeah I
again I'm not proud of this either it's
like Josh Peck followers but I used to
do shows because I was like there was
this guy that I was competitive with
yeah and I didn't want to go to a show
and I was like he's going I better go I
would go yeah and that's not great but
you know whatever gets the car running
going yeah I know that's always the
thing and I feel like I you know I
sometimes talk about this a lot about
like you know keeping your eyes on your
own paper and like not trying to compare
yourself to what other people have and
you know to
um I wasted a lot of time being jealous
of people early in my career and still
sometimes have a real ax to grind about
you know sort of you know it gets
shorter and shorter those periods of
time but still I'm like why him
um it still happens and so it's like as
much as I like to say like oh it's
that's wasted energy it's not a little
bit of it yeah it does keep you focused
and that to give you a pass and some
understanding that's a remnant of a of a
Consciousness that you develop to get
you where you are but what's interesting
is that country business doesn't serve
us anymore it's like milkshake like we
drink a milkshake in the caveman and US
goes like this is dense calories and
sugar and fat we should eat this every
day yeah it doesn't serve us anymore no
that can you can lay down those arms but
it's nice to see that you realize that
because I know a lot of people at your
level that are still [__] panicked
and weird sure and yeah yeah but yeah
less less jealousy but man oh man
especially in my like early 20s like
let me ask you this about those lines
for the Broadway yeah open calls did you
was there a community to it and a very
specific question did people ever save a
line like I'd be in a line at the comic
store uh comic strip for an audition and
maybe you know hold the line I know
they're coming and or they're going to
lunch and they're going to come back
that's very nice you're there for 12
hours like waiting for something just
waiting did it grow like that a little
bit it did you would see the same people
and um yeah you would run into the you
know start recognizing the same faces
and it's all very sort of like official
with numbers and like so there's no like
saving a place for anyone right but
right if you're sitting on the ground on
46th Street you know outside the Actors
Equity Building
um for eight hours like yeah you're
gonna start making small talk with
people but it was you know I think back
very sort of fondly on that time because
it was as much as I wasn't working and
there's a lot of instability in a lot of
areas of my life it was also it was
really exciting it was an exciting it's
an exciting time to be
you know was it was exciting time to be
in New York to be like feeling like I'm
starting a career maybe one day
um which is you know sort of the I hope
that still exists on some level for
people because if it's if it has come
down to creating content alone in your
bedroom yes that's a very isolating way
to create and you're cutting off one of
the believe it or not I'm an extra
extroverted introverture but I'm an
introvert I like I like being alone I
like hanging out at home and I love that
it forced me into these situations and I
think if I had had the option to just do
it at home it would have been tempting
but I'm glad I don't know as I'm saying
that I'm like I didn't want to do this
over Zoom I'm still drawn to yeah yeah I
know it's always it's always better to
to do these things thank you for her
yeah you're very helping me in person
you don't know he has 90 by the way so
I'm looking for an hour like okay well
we'll bring it in for a landing all
right the meaning of life Andrew well
but it's a
well well
um
just to give you a a sense of what what
I'm going for is like it's just a safe
place to talk about any framework
for for the for the order or how you
live your life like is there any I know
that we're no longer Catholic but like
but is there any story you catch
yourself telling or believing just to
guide your life is there a symbol that
means something to you or is it all or
or are we where are you
um I think in terms of spirituality I do
find myself because it was sort of sort
of ingrained in My
DNA and in my sort of in just in the
daily habits of things I still do pray
which might shock some people
um and I've actually started doing that
more recently like a rosary like a
rosary it's my grandmother's Rosary yeah
so I pray with Josephine sleazeski's
Rosary yeah I know what is it Jolene
Josephine
so you're doing a repetitive it's almost
like a mantra it's a mantra and it's yes
I mean and it very much gets you into
the same I think in the you know the the
little experience I have with like
chanting or you know things like that
it's so similar you're saying the same
set of prayers over and over again that
do sort of like Center you and ground
you but when I am doing it I find that
specifically I am thinking mostly about
my grandmother also my father who is
also dead but um like thinking about
those so it's not thinking about those
people it's not so much like praying to
God but like meditating on sort of my
really specifically lately is my
grandmother yeah who died in 1999
um but like I still think about her in
that way yeah it's not that I'm praying
to Josephine but maybe in a way that I
am we'll have some sort of comfort and
guidance and it sort of personalizes it
for me in a way that
um it's helpful for me to to get into
that mindset if I'm thinking about
someone that I can I can see and that I
had a relationship that you loved yeah
that opens your heart yeah yeah yeah I
mean that's it that's it how do we keep
the moisture of the heart going so you
have this Avatar I know your grandmother
existed but like it's a symbol that
opens your heart and quiets you and
centers you and then the repetition I
think it was Elizabeth Gilbert that said
it's like giving your monkey your brain
is like a monkey and you give it a pile
of buttons and you go just move these
buttons from this side to this side and
he does that and this is why we have
good ideas in the car as well because
you're you're literally part of your
brain is occupied so you can like free
up this other part of you so I think
that's wonderful and beautiful and what
about like a literal connection just
because it's indicative of other types
of beliefs do you feel
a connection still to your grandmother
or your father yeah very much so yeah
like it's a living relationship I mean
it is and it changes over time I mean
it's certainly something especially my
dad like
you know it's not something that I think
you ever really fully recover from
losing a parent so it's always sort of I
mean there are periods of time where
maybe I don't think about it as much and
then other periods of time that I think
about it a lot
um especially as I get older I find that
I think about him more I used to be like
you know the first couple years were
very difficult and then it would be sort
of more like larger markers of time
um for me like opening nights or you
know things like that where I'd be like
I wish she was here I wish you could see
this or like the first time I walked on
the Paramount set and like a Paramount
lot and was like you know walking around
being like my dad would get a kick out
of this like to see this yeah
um yeah so it goes in sort of it's it's
sort of evolved but I think he would be
I'm not just trying to pull your heart I
think they'd be so pleased to know that
that imprint remains you know that is
that sort of literal yeah living on Nest
I think it's beautiful the way your book
opens about what does it mean to be an
adult and what are the benchmarks yeah
and our parents are those I mean they
they like it matters so much more for
them to see these things so that we can
punch the ticket and go yeah I'm 30 or
whatever or whatever it might be yeah
yeah I thought that was a beautiful and
vulnerable way that you opened your book
well thank you talking about yeah and I
thought it was great that you talked
about like buying a house and I'm like
it made me pause and go like right it
was a big deal yeah or your first car
big deal things that you yeah because I
didn't you know go the route of like
having children so like that is a huge
marker obviously did you think about it
I never really thought about it no no
and now I date you know tuck my
boyfriend has two kids he has 10 year
old twins oh wow so that was not
something that I could have foreseen for
myself that I would be like out of a
step parent not a step parent because he
did you in a powdered way going I
couldn't
I didn't expect this
um but it's been it's been largely great
and and talk you know tuck uh always
really wanted kids yeah um that was
always something that was on his list
which is just you know it was not on
mine yeah yeah and now so you're as
basically well we don't live together
um uh so you know I'm not there all the
time right
um so I can't I'm not gonna take too
much because I have a label onto this no
no no she's like I know my my only
reason for reacting is just that like I
wouldn't want to be like I'm doing all
the hard work like tuck is doing all of
the hard work I sort of Bounce and I'm
like you guys want candy like I who
wants Taco Bell I kind of just like
breeze in and and often cause problems
interesting though you have that good
uncle good whatever we want to call this
energy like I think that would be really
I hope I'm glad it's happening for what
it's worth I'll give you my nieces and
nephews numbers and okay be like is he a
good uncle
is he good some of them would be like
not really quick follow-ups yeah do you
think when we die it's over are you open
to something else
I mean just two just two questions
I don't know I mean I think that
obviously as we were just discussing
like you know my grandmother and my
father like obviously that lives on
there's energy that is attached to that
and there is a you know a presence that
is left after they're physically not
here yeah so is that the continuation of
that life is how you were remembered and
how you're
how people think of you maybe
um I don't I I mean it's been a long
time since I've seriously considered
like heaven yeah or hell
um because I feel like there's a lot of
emphasis put on that as a kid so I sort
of like
probably yeah I mean I love all sorts I
mean I love the idea of like
reincarnation I think that's real fun
um everyone's always someone famous
which is strange
um usually yeah turns out I was but I
mean I do believe in that sort of like
you know you see it in kids a lot you
see it in like I remember when my one of
my nieces was born and she just like
genetically made faces that my
grandmother made and you see that not
that she was reincarnated as my
grandmother but like it's it you know
you just see that and kids you're like
there's no way that they would know it
cares they were affected by that but it
does sort of track through so maybe
that's the energy that yeah I don't know
you know what's interesting I've never
considered this but I'm with you
everybody when they're I they're like I
was Joan of Arc or I was I was gone to
here I was just and I was like yeah
that's convenient and strange and
egotistical but then it's also like
unless there really is just only one of
us and you're just kind of drawn to the
brighter lights like of your memory
maybe you know what I mean yeah just
like a dream do you think you're more
likely to have you ever done any of that
like past life I'm just so and I feel
like you're gonna relate to this I'm
such a
like our therapy thing I'm worried I
would make something up because I had a
great hypnotherapist oh okay I can get
to that lucid sort of dreamy place and
I've seen enough movies of ancient
Greece and Bible times
I'm John the Baptist or you know what I
mean and I my humiliation is too great I
would be too embarrassed to say I was
Marcus Aurelius you know like it would
be too hard it would have to let's put
it this way it would have to be an
overwhelming Vision yeah yeah a banality
and where do you get that I don't know
I've never seen banana
I've never been hypnotized before but
I'm fascinated by it well Cynthia Morgan
doesn't see anybody anymore but Cynthia
Morgan was my meaning she has a website
and you can just download them and they
might even be free I'm not sure or 99
Cents but you can download these Hypno
because it's the same she stopped doing
it in person I think because it's so
effective to just like listen really and
they they do it they guide you down
picture a place go down the stairs
here's the best part is you're Lucid the
whole time I thought hypnosis meant like
you black out and then you come back and
you're like what did I say you're there
you're just hypnotized it's it's very
bizarre but you're not like I don't want
to talk about it like you you could say
that you could say I don't want to talk
about it they're not like
you know drugging you yeah yeah but you
are my my arms used to levitate I'd just
be like this huh my arms would float
above my body did you go for a specific
reason initially I did yeah I had a car
accident and I swear to you I haven't
thought about this in a long time but
gratitude
I bumped my head my my skull like a so
my brain like a soapy sponge knocked
against my skull because I stopped short
and then like a dumb dumbass piece of
[__] I took a flight to Melbourne
Australia and got like super drunk and
took someone else's pain pills just like
stupid just like a bad move instead of
like what I would do now is like rest
and like cancel the trip and all these
things like just dumb just I guess I
guess early 30s and I swear I lost my
ability to be funny like and somebody
would pipe in and go did it ever come
back but like thank you thank you but
like I couldn't even understand jokes
like I became hyper literal I I could
still do stand up but I didn't really
understand why people were laughing it
was it was this brain fog that didn't
lift you want the punch line so I go to
hypnotherapy because I'm trying
everything Reiki obviously I go to
Western medicine first
uh somebody her name is Abby Emily she
emailed me on Facebook I think that's
how long ago it was and she goes it
sounds like your eyes might have gotten
knocked out of alignment and it's called
convergence efficiency and you do this
thing called pencil push-ups you just
have to like train your eyes to follow
something coming close to your face and
the brain fog went away isn't that crazy
wow but I went to everything how long
how long did you have to do that too it
came back real quick wow it came back
real quick and I remember the day I went
to see this doctor because I was at the
eye doctor today I was thinking about it
and he was like
um you have zero convergence efficiency
like out of a hundred he's like you have
none your eyes aren't working together
and I was like great shouldn't they have
been like goofy googly eyes but you
couldn't tell and I did that for like
three four weeks and it came back like
it was like my life came back wow and
then from that experience though I met
Cynthia Morgan who ended up being this
wonderful for other stuff you know but
it's true you can work on the yes if you
smoke or whatever it might be but um she
helped me a lot with wow yeah all right
I'm gonna look that up yeah Cynthia
Morgan I'm gonna hypnotize myself in the
car here's the last question let's go
let's get as I'm driving home you can
you can that's that's the great thing is
you can do it to your uh you can do it
to yourself I want to try it yeah I'll
try it we'll all try it right now what's
weird is we could kind of do it it's
it's a very very deep relaxation okay
and if somebody's guiding you and as a
performer you'll be kind of aware and
the piece of you that stays conscious is
very impressionable and that's how I
would describe it okay yeah but my
therapist like you're too uh strong of
mine to be hypnotized and now they work
together you're like watch me watch me
I'm weak as hell but it's not about
that's that's kind of the the
misconception I'm trying to correct is
that it's not a weakness yeah that
somebody like
like made you're under their control at
any moment if you really willed it you
could probably get up and you could at
least go like this is over I hate this
like okay all right I've oversold it no
no no
modern mammals um all these all these
treats okay the last and final question
is one that I love and uh it's a zero
press okay but can you think of a time
in your life that you left really really
hard maybe the hardest in your life
maybe tears are streaming down your face
here are a few like hypnosi things uh
maybe someone fell maybe someone farted
these are often things sure maybe you
were in a situation where you weren't
supposed to laugh yeah yeah these are
these are the prompts yeah and it
doesn't have to be a great story I'm
just wondering how old you are who are
you with
um
yeah the fur hmm
I feel like you just let one go that was
like I don't know if no no no just
thinking about
um yeah like going back like the thing
that you immediately came to mind when
you said that was laughing on stage yeah
to me there's like no better feeling
than trying not to laugh
audience just a little bit let us do it
yeah because you don't want to like I
mean it's always best when it's
something really terrible like you know
when it's a really like very tense scene
or it's like
um yeah so I I had again going back to
falsettos
um it was a it's a very it's a great
show but it ends very tragically and it
was you know it was very fulfilling to
do every night but there were times
where I would be laying in a hospital
bed on stage on Broadway dying and my
co-stars and I would be you know white
knuckling like just like gripping and I
would still be crying appropriately but
not for the right reasons
um and just like twisting these sheets
to be like please Jesus please let me
get through this but it also gives you
like such a rush yeah that you can't
possibly like you can't recreate that in
life because it's like the stakes are so
high you've got you know fifteen hundred
two thousand people you know watching
you and you're not supposed to be doing
that those are some of my like favorite
live performance moments are that you'll
never forget that answer that's
fantastic dying in a hospital bed yeah
in front of 2 000 people singing and
dying and oh I forgot in every line is
sung it's all sung yeah there were it
started because like well the the
details are not important but that was a
good moment but then I also when you
were like childhood then I was
remembering
um my best friend growing up this girl
Randy Newton that I'm still friends with
who we really like from Ricky Lake
um that we did like Children's Theater
together and one day I went over to her
house she was a she's a eccentric gal
we'll go with that and she she she was
like come over and see my bedroom I
redecorated and I was like cool I don't
know I was probably like 13 14. and what
she had done
on like much to her mother's horror was
she was like I made a canopy bed and I
was like how did you make a canopy bed
she took she took her curtains her bed
was in front of a window she took the
curtains and stapled them to the ceiling
essentially creating a canopy but with
like none of the posts and it took me a
second I remember like she was like
isn't it cool and I remember like
looking up at it and then seeing like oh
my God she took like office Staples and
stapled it to the ceiling and I about
wet my pants that I was laughing so hard
because I was like what was she it's
like Step Brothers it's like so weird
guacamole yeah
it was so weird but yeah that pops out
in my mind as well too just a strange
fantastic answers specific you reminded
me I haven't done a lot of theater but
in college I did rumors Neil Simon sure
and it has that three-page monologue at
the end which is was my monologue to do
and um that I still get a little nervous
as if I have to still remember it I'm
like I was a Tuesday I can't but it
ended with as I'm pretending to be
someone else and I'm in a robe and it's
monikered monikered yeah monogrammed
monogrammed Monica hello okay
monogrammed monogram monocurred I think
is like naming someone thank you yeah
yeah thank you I think monogrammed
monogram there's my initials on the on
the but there's someone else's initials
so the monologue ends where I go let
monologue okay sorry the monologue and
monolith where I go
it sure is my name is and I'm supposed
to like look and I go Chester
McGillicuddy right and I I would open my
robe to reveal the monogram and I'm
doing it to this guy his name was Andy
Winston and every night I would go I
would do the sound of the robe opening
up I'd go
just so subtly like a comic book as long
as my name is
because I was so relieved to be through
the model and I can still see his face
being like like eye shaking like not
don't laugh
it was the Joya theater that's really
good isn't that a good one I you brought
it out well that's a it's a good one
there's one another one that I wrote
about in this book when I was doing Miss
Saigon in the Finger Lakes of New York a
really sad theater and at the end of
Miss Saigon spoiler
um Kim kills herself it's also Madame
Butterfly she kills herself there too
um but so she kills herself and
um one night when we were doing it like
the guy who was supposed to be in charge
of the like firing this like starter
pistol just didn't do it
so the poor girl who was Kim the woman
who was playing Kim it gets to the point
again this is a musical so it's all set
to music
so she sings her last thing and she's
supposed to you know kill herself and
instead she just went
[Laughter]
[__] laid down
like the other actors we were on stage
we were like what the monk
um trying to like be like oh Kim
and then I was supposed to like cradle
her dead body and I'm she's the corpse
is laughing
and I was laughing and everyone's
laughing and we're trying to sing and
laugh it was not good but she just
crumbled to the ground like well I guess
this is what's happening Kim's gonna die
of an aneurysm or something but that's
yeah my no gunshot God and then when I
asked the stage manager who's supposed
to do it I said I was like what happened
what happened back here like it's a end
of the show should be on the sheet music
let's let's do it yeah and he said how
did that affect you
I said how did it affect me like like in
front of tens of people and the Finger
Lakes doing Miss Saigon
it affected me deeply
the people who are awake
wanted to see how she died
do you remember do you remember in uh
extras where Ricky gervaises on stage
and goes how oh it's not Ricky but it's
the other guy he goes how many of you
are thinking of leaving an intermission
lastly he goes
leaving and they raise their hand I love
that they admit it that they're like oh
that's really good go on
theater oh live oh life oh life oh geez
thank you so much what a delight and I
got treats you got treats I got so many
things can you feel the magic mine I do
I'm wired it's great right I really do
like it I'm gonna give you a little box
of it and try it when you when you write
your third book I hope yes or your next
uh movie film do more stress less that's
it they're gonna love that dude you're
joking
I'm pretty calm
um wincing anal the corpse is laughing
Andrew Reynolds like channels would you
please say keep it crispy the details
don't matter it's just how we end the
show keep it crispy there it is
what a delight and I love your hair that
yours too we switch coats let's switch
coats
[Music]